Speaker 1: All right. Listen, I know people in my
audience, some people in my audience are going to
get mad at me because there are people in
my audience who love Marianne Williamson
and they say Marianne is willing to make
criticisms of the status quo that many candidates
won't make. But I'm sorry, guys, I can't take
the New Age self-help gurus seriously. And I am
going to tell you what I think. And I know some of
you will be mad and you're going to email me and
that's okay. It's great that Marianne Williamson
is willing to say things like Both parties are
widely controlled by corporations. That's great.
She says it. It's not the type of thing you hear
Joe Biden say. But that notwithstanding, I am
not super excited about Marianne Williamson
announcing that she will be challenging President
Joe Biden for the 2024 Democratic nomination.
I'm just not excited. I don't believe that she is
someone who could seriously do the job. And it is
very difficult for me to take her seriously based
on her versus basically being a version of Deepak
Chopra. That's that's the way I know. Perfectly
nice individual. I've had her on the program.
I love her. Whole thing about we need more love
and all it. I love all of it. But this is not
something that I'm going to get excited about. And
I'll talk a little bit about it. And I know there
are people in my audience who like this. The fact
that Marianne Williamson makes criticisms that
many Democrats aren't willing to make doesn't to
me mean that she should be president. There's lots
of people that make criticisms that I find to be
real good criticisms that I wouldn't go and say,
well, make them president. She was able to gain a
big Reddit and Twitter following. She capitalized
on some meme culture. She's interesting. I get it.
She holds some reasonable left wing views that I
perfectly well agree with. She's for Medicare for
All, as I think she's for DOCA granting some kind
of permanent status for those who were brought to
the U.S. undocumented before they were adults. I
think she's for the Green New Deal. She seems very
serious about climate change. That's all great.
Is there any evidence that she can or would
actually be able to do anything about it?
But more importantly, I just can't take people
seriously when they have a history of touting all
sorts of woo woo pseudo science, including sort
of flirting with anti-vax stuff, although she's
kind of backed off of it a little when some of the
repercussions weren't so good. She's promoted this
prosperity gospel stuff that you often hear from
the Christian preachers. You can look at her 2012
book for examples of that. She sounds like Deepak
Chopra half the time with these unintelligible
quotes that are sort of like meant to sound
profound, but they don't really mean anything.
Just one example is when she said everyone feels
on some level like an alien in this world, because
we are we come from another realm of consciousness
and longing for home. Oh, wow. But that just as
easily could be a Deepak Chopra quote. Another
example. Yin is feminine. Earth Yang is masculine.
Sky. When God is seen as he, the soul is seen
as she just archetypes. Spirit impregnates soul.
It's just not for me. It's not for me. One other
one. God is big. Swine flu is small. C Every
cell of your body filled with divine light. Pour
God's love on our immune systems. Truth protects.
It's just not for me, guys. Okay, So. Totally
fine that she's running. Good for her. I have
no problem with her running. She should run if
she wants to. It's just not for me. And hopefully
people in my audience understand that now. One
argument that I saw, three people emailed me about
this, and all three said the same thing. Marianne
Williamson is going to push Biden to the left.
I don't see how. And what I mean by that is if
Biden runs for reelection, there's not going to
be like a real primary. And Marianne Williamson
isn't going to get on the debate stage with Joe
Biden. Now, you could say, well, she should. She
should be, but. She's not going to push. Biden
left because if Biden runs, she's not going to get
on the debate stage. No one will pay attention.
And I do think it's also important to mention that
if she somehow managed to become the nominee and
somehow managed to become president, she would
get nothing done. She would literally get nothing
done. She doesn't know how to get bills passed.
She has no idea about any of that stuff. And I
have no confidence if the completely impossible
were to happen, if someone paid attention and
she won the nomination and she became president.
I don't think she would be able to get anything
done. I don't believe that it is serious. I think
it's perfectly fine and interesting. I completely
support her right to run, but it is not for me.
Email me insults. I'm ready. Folks will have all
of today's clips on our Instagram, which you can
find by searching Instagram for David Pakman show.